(light bright music)
We are going to switch gears
and do the first of two presentations
on women's health to get through everything.
I still have nothing to disclose.
Here are our learning objectives,
and we're going to start with the discussion
of abnormal uterine bleeding,
which remember is menstrual flow outside
of either normal volume, regularity or frequency.
Now normally it's simply a disruption
of the normal physiology.
So there at the top, you're at the pituitary.
The FSH is what's going to induce ovarian follicles.
They produce estrogen.
The estrogen is like fertilizer
for the endometrium and it promotes growth.
The LH surge will then prompt the ovulation.
The result in corpus lutetium,
once you have your ovulation,
is what is going to secrete progesterone.
And that's gonna be important for stabilizing that
lush lawn that you've developed inside the endometrium.
And then in the absence of a pregnancy,
the estrogen and progesterone fall
and you get rid of all of that lining.
Now most people think,
oh my gosh, I'm gonna bleed to death.
And I understand that.
But actually, in any cycle,
only about 80 CCs of blood is lost.
Most of this, of course, is going to be tissue.
Let's start with this question.
A 39-year-old G2P2, she presents for follow-up.
She was seen two weeks ago
with a complaint of 13 months of infrequent periods.
Otherwise healthy, non-smoker, no medications,
breastfed both of her children for more than 12 months.
The oldest child is 10.
Vitals are normal, BMI is 24.8.
Her physical exam was in normal limits
including the pelvic exam.
The most recent Pap was 11 months ago.
Negative for an intraepithelial lesion, HPV negative.
Urine pregnancy test is negative.
A serum TSH and prolactin are within normal limits.
So here is the question.
Which one of the following
is the best initial approach in this patient?
Now as you're answering this question,
remember it doesn't say, what would you do?
It says of the following, which is the best, okay?
Okay, and 52, 51% of you chose the correct answer.
You would prescribe a 35 microgram ethinyl estradiol
combination contraceptive pill daily.
Here you want to use a monophasic pill.
Now, what's the diagnosis here?
We've got anovulatory bleeding.
So we've got a lot of estrogen on board,
insufficient progesterone to stabilize the endometrium.
And you basically your endometrium
outgrows its blood supply.
Now, if you have abnormal uterine bleeding and ovulatory,
this is irregular or infrequent periods,
your progesterone deficient, estrogen dominant.
The issue here is that the estrogen
is the gasoline, unfortunately,
which will potentially increase your risk
for hyperplasia and then dysplasia.
Now what are the commonly associated terms here?
I could have amenorrhea, I could oligomenorrhea,
I could metrorrhagia, or I could have DUB.
Ovulatory is where I have regular cycles.
I'm not bleeding between them.
However, there's a change in the menstrual products.
Either I am having excessive amounts,
clots or some of my patients call 'em clogs.
I'm like, "You've got clogs coming out?"
"Yeah, Dr. Weismiller, big clogs."
But they also vomit.
Okay, very heavy periods
or the duration is greater than eight days.
Now let's start with anovulatory.
If you are an adolescent,
it's secondary to an immature hypothalamic-pituitary axis.
The other end of the cycle, which is perimenopause,
is the other big differential.
If you're not one of those,
any other time it's gonna be considered abnormal.
And what do we gotta be thinking about?
Well, do they have uncontrolled diabetes?
Is there an eating disorder?
Do they have a thyroid disorder?
Is there a prolactinoma?
Are they on a medication they can cause this?
Do they have PCOS and are they pregnant?
Dr. Weismiller, it's impossible for me to be pregnant.
Well, you're pregnant.
Well, how'd that happen?
(students laughing)
Here's the evaluation.
You always do a pregnancy test.
You know, I have residents come in and they'll say,
"Yeah, I'm gonna send somebody to wherever."
I'm like, "Have you done a pregnancy test?"
Oh, I didn't think about that.
Okay, pregnancy test, CBC,
gotta look for thyroid disorder and prolactin.
Now, 45 is the new 35.
If they are over than 45
and I've got anovulatory bleeding in a patient
where I cannot say this is a normal physiologic event,
then they're gonna need some type of evaluation,
i.e. an endometrial biopsy.
Because what am I looking for?
Hyperplasia, potentially dysplasia.
If they're under 45,
where am I concerned about that hyperplasia, dysplasia?
Well, they've got chronic anovulation,
they have diabetes.
There's a family history of colon cancer
'cause that's a question of Lynch syndrome.
They're infertile.
They have null parity, obese, tamoxifen,
all these things which drive estrogen up.
More fuel on the fire.
So if they're an adolescent or if I'm under 45
and there's not a risk factor for endometrial cancer,
and we'll look at that in just a second,
then they get long-term medical therapy.
And any of those can be used.
Any of those can be used there.
Now if they don't respond,
those are the patients who get an endometrial biopsy.
If the results are normal,
they get a transvaginal ultrasound
'cause they need to look for structural abnormality.
If the etiology is still unclear,
they're gonna go for a hysteroscopy.
Now if they're less than 45,
recurrent anovulation
or there's other risk for endometrial cancer,
or I'm concerned because they're over 45,
then they automatically go for an endometrial biopsy.
Now keep in mind here,
why are they going for a biopsy
versus a transvaginal ultrasound?
'Cause we're not talking about
postmenopausal bleeding here.
Transvaginal ultrasound to look for endometrial thickness
is in postmenopausal women, right?
If you're premenopausal,
your endometrial stripe should be thick, right?
Good, good, good, good.
Okay, normal endometrium,
they go on back to the same
medical regimen we had on the previous slide.
Hyperplasia without atypia,
they get treated with a progesterone
and then re-biopsied.
Hyperplasia with atypia or adenocarcinoma.
Of course, they're going to go on for definitive treatment.
Now, why was our patient at low risk for cancer?
All the stuff in red.
Otherwise healthy, non-smoker, no medications,
breastfed, normal BMI,
physical exam is normal, Pap, HPV.
That's why this is a patient specific question.
Now in the context of this,
the other big common issue is PCOS.
You have to have two of the three of the following.
Hyperandrogenism, ovulatory dysfunction,
and polycystic ovaries.
What you see here is an altered luteinizing hormone.
You see insulin resistance
and this possible predisposition to hyperandrogenism.
We really don't understand why women develop this,
but you need to suspect it if on history.
Abnormal periods, fluctuations in weight,
there are cutaneous findings,
and you have to ask about common comorbidities.
And what are those?
Metabolic syndrome, obesity, type II diabetes,
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease, sleep apnea.
These women are at increased risk
for cardiovascular disease and for mood disorders.
Now, two of these have to be positive
as we look at the diagnosis.
These are called the Rotterdam criteria.
So you have to have hyperandrogenism.
Clinically, this can be determined
or you can do a chemically?
Either one.
Two, you have to have ovulatory dysfunction.
That can be oligomenorrhea or amenorrhea.
And then if you don't have those two,
then you're going to need to get a ultrasound.
Single ovary is all you need to document this.
Now here's the evaluation.
We exclude pregnancy.
Now we sometimes have to exclude causes
other than PCOS for the hyperandrogenism.
Thyroid disease, prolactin disease,
they could have a 21-hydroxylase deficiency.
Cushings, acromegaly.
You only have to go looking for those
if they have physical findings
that suggest those conditions.
There's no need to get laboratory testing
if they don't have suggestive physical findings.
And then you can document
the biochemical hyperandrogenemia,
total bioavailable or free testosterone,
or you can do DHEA-S.
Any of those can be done.
Now why do they get this insulin resistance?
Of course, this is where insulin sensitivity decreases.
With that, your body says,
well, you need more 'cause it's not working very well.
So you see an insulin release
and circulating insulin increases.
Now unless you have a metabolic syndrome present,
you will see normal glucose tolerance.
The resistance happens when cells in your muscle,
cells in fat, cells in liver
just are not responding to insulin as they should.
This can be a temporary issue.
It can be a chronic issue.
When we are thinking about PCOS,
that insulin resistance
is what stimulates the ovarian androgen production.
That's what leads to the anovulation.
And this prolonged anovulation
is where you can lead to the development
of these enlarged ovaries with all these cysts.
The hyperinsulinemia along with the hyperandrogenemia,
that is what interferes
with the secretion of the normal gonadotropins
from our pituitary gland.
And that's when we get the change in the LH surge.
And its normal diurnal variation,
which leads to the altered menses.
How do we manage this?
Oligomenorrhea and amenorrhea, OCPs.
Hirsutism, OCPs.
Infertility, clomiphene,
but the better drug is letrozole.
Only use metformin if you have insulin resistance.
I know what everybody thinks,
but the data shows it does not improve fertility.
And then lastly, the weight issue.
That has a positive effect on fertility
and it has a positive effect on your metabolic profile.
Here are key recommendations.
Put those with your study materials.
Here's our next question.
36-year-old G3P2A1 presents
a 14-month history of vein amenorrhea,
hot flashes, and vaginal dryness.
She previously had normal menses
and takes no medications.
Past medical and surgical histories are negative.
Patient is 66 inches tall and her BMI is 23.5.
Her vital signs are normal.
Physical exam is normal.
Laboratory studies reveal a negative pregnancy test.
Normal TSH, prolactin, and elevated LH and FSH levels.
The most likely diagnosis here.
Functional hypothalamic amenorrhea,
intrauterine synechiae,
primary ovarian insufficiency, or Turner's.
Okay, so this is primary ovarian insufficiency.
So as we think about secondary amenorrhea,
it could be PCOS,
but it can be any of these other five
that are listed there.
In practice though,
the most common reason people will be amenorrheic
is there on a progestin only contraceptive,
which is why they like them so much.
Because are you ready for this?
Hold onto your seats.
Funded research has demonstrated
that women prefer fewer periods.
(students laughing)
Sorry.
I mean people got funded
to do that study.
I did it one night at the dinner table.
Hey ladies, what do you think?
Why do we always talk about this stuff at dinner?
Steps in the evaluation here.
Rule out the pregnancy, thyroid disease.
And now I've gotta determine the relative estrogen status
with a progestin challenge test.
How do I do this?
I get five to 10 milligrams
of hydroxy progesterone acetate,
Any bleeding when I withdraw that
even a spot is considered positive.
Now if they have an elevated TSH or prolactin,
of course they've got hypothyroidism or pituitary disease.
But keep in mind
you are gonna have other stigmata of hypothyroidism
before they present with abnormal periods typically.
The flip side to that
is you're never gonna find a patient with hypothyroidism
who comes in and says,
"I think it's my gland because my weight is up."
Okay, it's impossible.
It's just not gonna happen.
They're gonna have other findings.
Now, the progestin challenges
those who have a normal TSN chip prolactin.
If they have a withdrawal bleed, I've got anovulation.
Now, anovulatory amenorrhea.
Adequate estrogen, positive progestin challenge.
PCOS is a cause of this.
I don't have progesterone being adequately produced.
Unopposed estrogen stimulation.
My risk of endometrial cancer is up,
and therefore my treatment is typically to use an OCP
or a progestin to help stabilize that endometrium.
Now what about if the TSH is normal,
prolactin is normal,
you do the progestin challenge
and you don't have a withdrawal bleed?
Then I have to give both an estrogen
and progestin challenge.
No withdrawal bleed there.
I'm dealing with some type of outflow tract obstruction.
If I have a withdrawal bleed
following my estrogen and progesterone,
then I'm gonna measure an FSH and LH.
If it's high,
I am gonna have primary ovarian insufficiency.
If it's low or normal, I get an MRI.
If that's normal, I got hypothalamic amenorrhea.
Now with hypothalamic amenorrhea
or hypogonadotropic hypogonadism,
lower normal FSH or LH,
normal prolactin, low levels of endogenous estrogen.
You got a normal MRI of the sella.
They get a positive withdrawal bleed
from the estrogen-progestin challenge.
They typically have anorexia or bulimia,
high levels of stress, high intensity exercise,
or some type of chronic illness.
Here, one of the concerns
is decreased bone density.
We don't know if it's increases the risk of fractures.
You wanna make sure they decrease intensive exercising.
Is that as a cause?
And wouldn't you love this?
Just get that BMI above 20.
Typically, we're not talking with patients about
you need to get your BMI above 20.
Okay, now ovarian failure.
It could be primary.
It could be postmenopausal.
If they have the absence of secondary sex characteristics,
you've got gonadal dysgenesis.
The most common thing we see in the United States,
although not common, is Turner syndrome.
The onset of heavy menses at menarchy
is often the first sign of what disorder?
Hemophilia A, von Willebrand, leukemia or ITP?
Okay, von Willebrand, exactly.
So this gets us to ovulatory
abnormal uterine bleeding.
This is not estrogen driven.
So less than 1% of women develop cancer or hyperplasia.
The differential here
is typically a bleeding disorder.
You could have hypothyroidism, advanced liver disease,
or you could have a structural lesion.
Now here's the evaluation.
Same laboratory tests.
What do we need to do
in terms of looking for a bleeding disorder?
CBC, PT/PTT.
You do not have to do a fibrinogen or thrombin.
You should do this in adolescence,
and in an older woman,
i.e. beyond adolescents,
if they have one or more of the following risk factors.
There's a family history of a bleeding disorder
or my menses are lasting greater than seven days.
It's impairing activities.
There's a history of treatment of anemia,
or I've got a history of excessive bleeding
with things like a tooth extraction
or when I had a delivery
or when I had a termination or some form of surgery.
Now, imaging here, typically this is only done in adult.
Here, this is where we start with imaging.
You do not wanna start with imaging
if you think that this is an ovulatory.
You start with imaging when it's ovulatory,
'cause it could be a structural defect.
If that's normal,
then they get an endometrial biopsy.
Same exact age cutoffs.
Now, if we evaluate for the bleeding disorder,
we've got a bleeding disorder,
that goes off to be treated.
The imaging is normal.
I get a endometrial biopsy.
Now, if I find on my imaging I've got a fibroid,
that can be fixed.
Polyp, refer.
Normal imaging results,
we go back to the same medical treatment
we had for anovulatory.
So here's a summary of treatment
of abnormal uterine bleeding.
Medically, sometimes it needs to be done surgically,
myomectomy, hysterectomy, ablation.
As we look at these,
surgery, hysterectomy reduces menstrual bleeding
more than medical treatment at one year.
Not surprising.
Oral medication tends to suit
a minority of women in the long term.
A levonorgestrel intrauterine system
is actually FDA approved
to treat abnormal uterine bleeding.
It's a better alternative to surgery.
One study showed that 69% of women
who were scheduled for a hysterectomy
when they had the intrauterine system put in
canceled their surgery.
Both are safe and effective.
Here are sort recommendations related to that.
You can put those with your study folder.
Perimenopausal bleeding.
The endometrial biopsy is done on risk
as we've already looked at.
We can treat it with progestins OCPs.
This is a place in my practice
where I use low dose OCPs a lot.
You can use the levonorgestrel intrauterine system,
or you can put 'em on hormone therapy.
So if they're having hot flashes,
you could use this in terms of hormone therapy,
which is a much lower dose of estrogen and progesterone
than having them on a combined OCP.
The hormone therapy here,
you tend to do better with sequential
so that you're typically giving 21 days of estrogen
and then 14 days of progesterone at the last 14 days,
as opposed to putting them on continuous.
This will prevent hyperplasia,
but you don't have contraception
'cause it's such a low dose.
Here's choosing wisely.
Do not obtain a FSH level in women in their 40s
to identify the menopausal transition
as the cause of irregular
or abnormal menstrual bleeding.
Next question.
55-year-old postmenopausal woman
presents with two days of vaginal bleeding or spotting.
She initiated hormone therapy 10 months ago
because of significant nocturnal hot flashes.
Which one of the following statements is most accurate?
Vaginal bleeding is uncommon after HT is initiated;
more than 40% of females experience
vaginal bleeding after menopause;
transvaginal ultrasound is appropriate
for the initial evaluation
of postmenopausal bleeding;
the most common cause
of postmenopausal bleeding is fibroids.
So transvaginal ultrasound
is the appropriate initial evaluation
for postmenopausal bleeding.
Now if we're thinking about
the differential diagnosis here,
the most common reason
for postmenopausal bleeding is polyps actually, polyps.
This gets us to a brief discussion of cancers.
Keep in mind,
here are the key facts on endometrial cancer.
It's the most common gynecologic malignancy.
85% of women with endometrial cancer will present
with abnormal uterine bleeding postmenopausally.
85% of postmenopausal bleeding
is not endometrial cancer.
Think about that for a moment.
No screening test.
Strongest association with reduced risk.
Combined hormonal contraception,
50% reduction in risk.
The protection lasts
up to 15 years after discontinuation.
The driver for most of this is estrogen.
So any question where they're older,
nulliparity, history of infertility,
all anything that's gonna drive estrogen persistence
is what's going to be the risk factor here.
Transvaginal ultrasound
is how this should be evaluated.
Since we don't have a screening test,
the important thing to remind postmenopausal women
is any bleeding, even a spot, I need to know about.
Dr. Weismiller, you wanna hear just about
a spot of bleeding?
Yes, call me at home.
I wanna know about it.
Very important.
Okay, here are the practice recommendations
for that, endometrial cancer.
Ovarian cancer.
This is the most lethal.
Highest risk factor: genetic predisposition.
We don't have a screening test.
The Ca-125 is used to monitor.
Increased risk: estrogen,
genetic syndromes, obesity.
Decreased risk, breastfeeding, OCP use, Depo.
Prevention, besides OCPs and DMPA or Depo,
breastfeeding, tubal sterilization,
what we call an opportunistic salpingectomy.
'Cause as we said earlier in the week,
the ovarian cancer arises from the tube,
not from the ovary.
Screening, we don't have one.
High risk family history,
you can offer a referral for genetic counseling
the same way we did breast cancer.
Hello, does anybody in the family have breast,
ovarian, peritoneal, or tubal cancer?
There's the clinical recommendations
based on ovarian cancer
and we go to cervical cancer,
which is an STD caused by an STI.
The only other risk factor associated independently
with cervical cancer is smoking.
Here's the current recommendation for screening.
Cytology alone every three years
between the ages of 21 and 65,
or from 30 to 65
HPV testing plus cytology or primary HPV testing.
Now the American Cancer Society
has already moved to a recommendation
of primary HPV testing
and they don't start screening until age 25.
The USPSTF is looking at this right now.
They're gonna move it to 25 too, I'm sure.
When the most recent consensus guidelines
were published way back in 2012,
the consensus panel said
the data all supports not screening
for cervical cancer until age 25.
We feel uncomfortable with that.
Okay, under 25, the ACS says, do not screen.
Over 65, do not screen.
Hysterectomy with removal of the cervix.
Somebody asked yesterday,
if the patient doesn't know
if they had their cervix removed,
how do we find out?
No, you do a physical exam
and you look for it or you feel for it, okay?
But if they've had removal of the cervix,
you do not do a Pap.
Even if the cervix was removed
because they had endometrial cancer,
you do not do a Pap.
No screening for cervical cancer.
Now, if you're doing primary HPV screening,
this is how it's done.
You collect it just like you would
if you were doing cytology.
If it comes back type 16 or 18,
they go directly for colposcopy.
If it's one of the other 12 high risk types
that are detected in the cobas test,
cytology is then done.
They just go pull out that vial that you sent them.
If it's negative, they go to routine screening
every three to five years.
Now, in terms of follow-up now,
I don't think you're gonna have a question
on the exam on this
because now the newest guidelines
looking at management of abnormalities is risk-based.
So it's not just, oh, I had this with the last one.
That's where I'm going.
So I think knowing the screening
is the most important thing here.
How do we prevent this?
Condoms, quit smoking and immunize.
The non-valent human papillomavirus vaccine
prevents genital warts.
It prevents cervical and anal cancers,
penile cancer, and hopefully head and neck cancer.
There's a large study going on now
because we now have more head and neck cancer,
secondary HPV in the US
than we do cervical cancer,
and most of it's in men.
I saw a patient within the last two weeks
recently diagnosed with a HPV positive
head and neck cancer, 53.
Okay, who gets a pelvic exam?
Who knows?
If you're symptomatic with something,
you get a pelvic exam.
But otherwise, the most recent review
of the literature by the USPSTF
says it's a category I as to how often you do it.
Menopause, the two big issues
are vasomotor instability and atrophic vaginitis.
About 85% of women will experience vasomotor symptoms.
90% of them will bring it up to the doctor.
We don't bring it up to them.
And of the majority of women
who would benefit from treatment,
60% never get treated.
Very sad state.
How do we treat?
We do an estrogen containing hormone therapy.
There are non-hormonal medications.
There's non-pharmacologic.
The non-pharmacologic, CBT and hypnosis.
They're effective for short-term reduction.
Other issues, herbal, botanical, exercise,
tai chi, acupuncture.
The data says they don't work for vasomotor symptoms.
If they work for your patient, fine.
But they don't work in terms of large studies.
Systemic hormone therapy is the most effective.
Use whatever vehicle to deliver it as you want.
What is not effective for vasomotor symptoms?
Progesterone only medications, testosterone alone,
or compounded bioidentical hormones?
The North American Menopause Society,
most effective treatment for vasomotor symptoms
and genital urinate symptoms is hormone therapy.
It's been shown to prevent bone loss.
We know that.
The risk depend on my age, vehicle used, et cetera,
and you always have to individualize this.
The systemic formulations
of which there's only one transdermal systemic,
these are typically gonna be preferred
for vasomotor symptoms.
Vaginal estrogen formulations,
these are minimally absorbed.
They're gonna be used for atrophic vaginitis.
Now, here's the scoop.
If you're younger and within 10 years of menopause,
the benefit outweighs the risk of hormone therapy.
If you're older,
over 60 or more than 10 years since menopause,
the risk outweighs the benefit.
There is no age by definition to stop this.
If they're benefiting, you can continue.
In my practice at two years,
we typically start having a discussion annually.
I got patients in their 70s
still on hormone therapy.
Contraindications, I've got unexplained vaginal bleeding.
There's a history of a stroke,
history of thromboembolism.
Testosterone alone does not help vasomotor symptoms.
If you combine it with HT
because they have vasomotor symptoms,
which is the only indication
for systemic hormone therapy,
you see improved sexual function scores
and improved number of sexually satisfying experiences.
Here are our practice recommendations.
And lastly, atrophic vaginitis.
What's important here?
The urinary symptoms look just like a UTI,
including what you will see on the UA.
I'm here, Dr. Weismiller,
I got another urinary tract infection.
Never met the patient.
I look at the chart.
They've had four urine cultures.
They're all negative.
You've never had a urinary tract infection, what?
Do you have any vaginal dryness?
Oh my gosh, it's dry like the Sahara.
Yeah, painful urination,
blood in the urine, increased frequency.
Moisturizers and lubricants are first line.
Vaginal estrogen is then added.
Typically, you're not going to need
to add any progesterone
because they don't have systemic reactions.
Non-pharmacologic is not sufficient,
and I'm not touching down there
or I can't get there.
Ospemifene is a serum
that acts as an estrogen agonist in the vagina
has no clinically significant effect
on the endometrium or breast, so that could be used.
If you have a history of breast cancer,
which is estrogen receptor positive of course,
those patients, even if there's a low risk of recurrence,
no estrogen systemically,
maybe a low dose estrogen vaginally,
but you're gonna have to talk with your oncologist
and the patient together.
Those are our practice recommendations.
Please keep in mind
if they give you a question
where they're on a vaginal estrogen preparation
and they have postmenopausal bleeding,
you still have to evaluate the endometrium.
Okay, those are our sore recommendations,
and we are done.
Thank you very much.
(audiences applauding)
(light bright music)